unfortunately this is coming from my
Christian perspective Sharia law is
probably preferable to what we have
right now the blatant sexuality the
killing of babies they don't allow that
in Sharia law so as far as that's
concerned they're probably a little bit
more just than we are well you know the
interesting thing Stephan is that when
Muslims around the world complain about
the United States they always talk about
the decadence and one of the main things
they mention is the amount of
pornography that is produced in the
United States and then shipped overseas
and so they rightly accused the United
States of corrupting the morality of the
entire world and it's just embarrassing
it's humiliating
that we have given them that that how do
we argue against that we can't when you
show them that there is something
comparable in their own scriptures then
that will help them to understand the
the point about Islam as as well
sometimes they think that whatever is
modern democracy that this is what their
Bible teaches but they'll be surprised
if you show them that in fact there are
verses in the Bible that do not support
the modern democracy I'm not saying that
the modern democracy is bad but I'm
saying that one cannot say oh your Islam
is wrong because your Islam does not
support democracy and our Christianity
is right because our Christianity
supports democracy for his Christianity
to support democracy that support has to
come from his sacred scripture the Bible
itself and in fact the Bible does not
support that what the Bible supports is
a theocracy in theocracy Jacque Rossi me
see us for God you know the war deals
for God in some of the European
languages or deuce so the Greek word is
Theo's and from that means God and from
that we have theocracy which means God
ruling that's the term theocracy so
that's what the Bible supports a
situation in which God is ruling it is
mentioned in the Bible that easily
sallam taught his disciples a prayer
and the Christians referred to it as the
Lord's Prayer what do they refer to as
the Lord's Prayer because they called he
Saleh Salaam the Lord and they say this
is the prayer that he taught them so
this is the Lord's Prayer right they
consider that prayer to be important
when I went to school as a boy in Guyana
it was a government-run school and
Christianity was being promoted in one
way or another sometimes openly
sometimes in a covert manner and one of
the things looking back is that we find
it surprising that we as Muslim children
were reciting this same Lord's Prayer
that's why I know that prayer so very
well and I don't know if the situation
was similar in Bangladesh or in some
other countries that people may be
reciting the Lord's Prayer even though
they are Muslims so that prayer says our
Father who art in heaven hallowed be thy
name
if that means your name be blessed like
tabarak a smoke and then thy kingdom
come
[Music]
Momoko catotti something like this a
valley a team will cook let your kingdom
come
that's the idea let let this let your
will be done on earth that's what the
prayer says thy will be done on earth as
it is in heaven so as you are ruling in
heaven let your will be done on earth as
well because what was happening in
heaven whatever allah subhanaw taala
commands is carried out by the angels
right so his will is being done in
heaven so this prayer is saying as it is
being done in heaven let your will be
done on earth as well
so that means in this player Christians
are praying for the law of God to be
executed on the earth so that his law on
his will whatever he rules that would be
carried out now when we recited this
prayer as kids we had no idea it meant
all of this and maybe many a Christian
is reading this and they don't realize
that they're actually praying for a
theocracy when they are praying this
prayer maybe they don't have to did mind
that this is what the prayer means but
this is what essentially it means now
it's all a Salam is said to be the
Prince of Peace and this is how
Christians conceive of him he is a
peaceful person and they think that if
there's any violence being done anywhere
this is wrong now we agree with a
peaceful outlook and our religion is
about peace as well but now our
Christian friends come to us with this
like chip on the shoulder saying looks
like your religion is violent your
Mohammed is violent and our ASA peaceful
so now we have to turn the tables around
right say okay now you have some
questions about Islam you have some
questions about our Prophet Mohammed
peace be upon him and about this battle
or that battle or that event or that
situation you know all of these are good
questions and I'll be glad to answer
those questions for you but first will
you permit me to ask you a question and
now you asked him the question when it
is said that Jesus was the Messiah what
did this mean we know from the Quran
that easily Salam is called al maseeh ha
a sub no Maryam the Messiah Jesus son of
Mary now in the Bible - he is called in
a cyano what is meant by Messiah here
what is meant by Messiah in in the Bible
the it is being shown that ISA a Salaam
by being the Messiah that meant that he
will institute the law of God on earth
that means he will bring a Sharia
nowadays our Donald Trump south of the
border is worried about Muslims and
Sharia well this was a Sharia that he
would have brought there and we know
from the Quran
called Anjana min come sir Ottoman min
Hodja for each of you we have appointed
a Sharia and Andaman Hajj if path to
follow so they have a path they have a
Sharia and that Sharia is in the Bible
and easily Salam by coming as the
Messiah according to the New Testament
he would have instituted all of this he
would have instituted the Sharia of the
Bible on earth he would have thrown away
the Roman rule and he would have
instituted the law of God this is
according to the Bible what he was
supposed to do but of course he was not
successful in doing that according to
the Bible's own narrative and then
Christians adopted the idea that when he
comes back he will do it to the extent
that they have a book in the Bible known
as the book of Revelation that is the
last book of the Bible
and in that book of Revelation it's
called revelation if sometimes they also
call it apocalypse apocalypse which
means like something like the revelation
it's also like the end time what will
happen at the end time so in that book
it is described that when he saw a salam
comes back he will have a sword coming
out of his mouth now we know that hints
you know if you're looking at a Tarzan
movie or something like that maybe
Tarzan has a dagger in his in his mouth
right so in this case it is said that he
saw a salam will have a sword in his
mouth they his tongue itself will be the
sword like this word is coming out of
his mouth and with that sword he will
slay his enemies that's that's at the
end that's the final analysis so now if
in the final analysis he will come back
and he will slay his enemies then in
what sense do you say that he's the
Prince of Peace that means you have here
two conflicting ideas about easily
Salaam one idea is that he's the Prince
of Peace the other idea is that he's a
man of war and in fact this idea that
he'll be a man of war this is the final
analysis so even if a person is peaceful
for a time but then in the end he fights
well then in the end that's what
characterizes him right he is a fighter
in the end even though he was peaceful
for a time
so now knowing this you can turn the
situation around somebody comes to ask
you about some Battle of the prophet
sallallaahu Selim and you're often they
think that it's impossible for a prophet
to fight so they're saying oh if you're
a prophet muhammad peace be upon him
went in the battle that means he's not a
prophet of God so that's the objection
so now you can put that aside for the
moment
talk about a silence and I'm and now you
can say well let's come back to the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him the
battles that he engaged in war for
specific purposes mostly of a defensive
nature because people were attacking him
in this community naturally he had the
responsibility to protect his people and
so he rose to their defence and of
course many of those who are committing
violent acts in the name of Islam today
are not following the rules of Islam
because if they were there would not be
deliberately targeting civilians as they
do and it so happens that they're
killing more Muslims than others whereas
the Quran is very clear locked up too
low on for succumb do not kill your own
people and we find that many who are
dying today in Iraq and and elsewhere by
suicide bombings and they are Muslims so
it's become crazy if it looks like their
desire to kill has taken over their
intellect and they're choosing any
target so if they cannot find a military
target they're finding a civilian target
they cannot find a non-muslim civilian
target they find a Muslim civilian
target and of course they can justify
themselves by any means by saying ok
there aren't those are not really
Muslims or whatever but it shows that
their thinking is corrupt and what they
are practicing is not Islam so now we
can answer the question by attacking it
from these various ways Gandhi once said
the enemy is fear we think it is hate
but it is fear so let us replace this
fear with hope by taking the following
steps
try turning off the news for a minimum
of one week and see the positive effects
it has on your life from both an
optimism and productivity perspective
meet a Muslim Muslims should visit their
non-muslim neighbors and vice versa go
out for coffee or lunch get to know each
other
why because correct knowledge brings
about hope and removes the fear
consequently with this interaction a
mutual feeling of love will overcome the
hate at the end of the day we are all
human beings with diverse views and
perspectives we do not have to agree
with everything but we do have to and
want to live respectfully alongside each
other
all of us are from Adam and Adam was
from dirt
so let us humble ourselves read our
souls of unwarranted arrogance hate and
fear be hopeful and optimistic if you
have any questions then please ask a
Muslim thank you